[Musique]
et pour en parler nos invités bruno
bartocetti secrétaire zone sud gp police
et fo christelle pernette ergothérapeute
et militante syndicale à la cgt et
victoria tedeschi délégué national
associé au jeune république et un
bonsoir à vous tous avant de vous poser
une première question je vous propose de
voir ce sondage est là pour bfm tv de
cette semaine 76% des personnes
interrogées approuvent la vaccination
obligatoire pour les soignants et 58% se
disent pour l'extension du pass
sanitaires aux cafés restaurants et
centres commerciaux et christelle
pernette je commence avec vous qu'est ce
que cette enquête vous évoque
d'un côté les français semblent être
pour on vient de le voir avec ce sondage
mais d'un autre côté dix neuf mille
personnes dans les rues hier fronde ou
vraie colère une minorité qui s'agitent
comme des calmants bonne alors je pense
qu'il ya une vraie colère effectivement
notamment chez les soignants puisque
malgré tout les soignants on a quand
même été maltraité des soignants et les
personnels en général personnels
hospitaliers ont été assez mal traités
avec cette histoire de crise sanitaire
on a été adulé au début quand quand tout
le monde avait peur et que adulé tout en
ayant des personnes auxquelles on
demandait de changer le lieu
d'habitation on a eu des
applaudissements aux fenêtres et des
personnes qui étaient rejetés par leur
part leur voisinage
il ya eu pas mal de choses qui se sont
passées avant c'est à dire que ça
faisait très longtemps déjà que les
personnels hospitaliers étaient dans les
rues pour demander une augmentation du
nombre de personnel par rapport à la
prise en charge des personnes et
notamment en hiver avec la grippe
ensuite on a eu des miettes de ségur
avec 583 euros soit disant pour pour
nous reconnaître
183 euros qui n'ont pas été donné à tout
le monde bien évidemment puisque les
aides à domicile ça n'est pas le cas les
personnes qui sont en centre un centre
type ime autres qui ne sont pas
rattachés à un centre hospitalier n'y
ont pas droit non plus moi je me pose la
question de caisse qui ai cherchés par
rapport à tout ça depuis le début de la
crise comme il ya eu plus de 10000
démission de personnel hospitalier on
est en manque de personnels hospitaliers
à la cgt on leur l'estiment entre deux
cents 200 milles pour les hôpitaux sans
mise pour les maisons de retraite
et là on va imposer quelque chose qui va
faire que les gens non vaccinés seront
de fait suspendus voire voire licencier
donc vraie colère pour vous
christelle pernette bruno bartocetti
comment est ce que vous vous situez
alors nous si vous voulez d'un set dans
cette situation
nous allons continuer à travailler à
travers les circulaires qu'on nous
demande d'appliquer mais pour nous notre
priorité si je réponds à votre question
je l'espère à notre priorité c'est de
porter assistance à personne en danger
donc tout le reste et bien sûr ça fait
partie de notre travail
maintenant on va l'appliquer avec
pédagogie comme ça a été fait depuis le
début de cette crise de sant pere c'est
à dire que on va pas mettre un flic deux
dans chaque restaurant chaque endroit où
on va recevoir du public
bien évidemment on saura être amenés à
sanctionner
et encore une fois j'insiste bien sur le
sur le travail de tout contrôle à
travers la traverse de pédagogie et non
pas de la solution immédiate parce que
on comprend la colère des français
la pression est énorme à l'endroit de en
exemple des restaurateurs mais attention
immédiate alors que ses 55 euros pour
une personne qui ne présente pas son
sont pas sanitaires et on l'a vu un peu
aller jusqu à 45000 euros d'amendé voire
un an de prison pour un entrepreneur un
restaurateur ou un propriétaire de café
bruno bartocetti je me retourne vers
vous dans un instant juste avant
j'aimerais que vous regardiez gabriel
atta le porte parole du gouvernement qui
se montrait mal à l'aise sur la question
de la non vaccination des policiers
s'étaient sur europe 1 mardi à regarder
les policiers ne travaille pas dans des
établissements où enfin ce n'est pas la
même situation
les policiers sont certes au contact du
public on a mis en place une obligation
vaccinale pour les personnes qui
travaillent au contact de france est
particulièrement vulnérable donc bruno
bartocetti vous représentez les
policiers ces derniers n'ont pas
l'avocat cela vocation à contrôler vous
dites non pas la vaccination obligatoire
mais doivent quand même faire des
contrôles on peut les cas ils sont
appelés à faire des contrôles de la part
de l'exécutif
et c'est là on rencontre d'une énorme
difficulté dans notre profession nous et
nous exprimons nous aussi en interne
avait beaucoup de colère car je vous
rappelle qu'il ya un peu plus d'un an
on nous disait également qu'on pouvait
faire des contrôles simples masques bien
évidemment on n'avait pas de masque à
fournir aux policiers donc c'était
c'était c'était un argument qui était
donnée aujourd'hui on nous en donne un
autre que font les policiers aujourd'hui
puisqu'ils sont quand même responsables
de leurs actions bien de même ils vont
se faire vacciner vacciner dans la
grande majorité des cas bien évidemment
que monsieur chatel était mal à l'aise
on est en contact avec le public et on
doit au moins montrer qu'on est en
incapacité nous aussi de porter notre
notre pas sanitaires ou démontrer que
nous sommes vaccinés
c'est très difficile vous savez le
policier est avant tout citoyen il
faudra justement à travers ces mesures
là beaucoup de discernement dans le
cadre de son travail et victoria
tedeschi le chef de file des députés
lr votre camp damien abad a ajouté je
cite le général de gaulle a rendu
obligatoire le vaccin contre la
poliomyélite et il n'est pas un
dictateur pourtant gala merkel a dit
très récemment
je cite je ne pense pas qu'on puisse
gagner la confiance en changeant de cap
nous n'avons pas l'intention de suivre
la voie de la france la france est-elle
une dictature victoria était de skier
alors la france n'est certainement pas
une dictature en revanche je m'inscris
en opposition avec ce qu'a dit damien
abad parce que pour moi déjà la
comparaison entre emmanuel macron
général de gaulle et à minima spécieuse
et ensuite le vase le vaccin en question
doit au carré de référence de manière
vague n'est pas comparable à sfax simple
pour de multiples raisons
moi je voudrais je veux pas rentrer sur
la question de l'obligation vaccinale ou
la non obligation vaccinale mais plutôt
celle sur celles du passé ni terre et je
trouve ça très intéressant d'être
confronté et à une soignante et un
policier
parce que pour moi les soignants
effectivement ils ont peut-être des
craintes légitimes par rapport à ce
vaccin et elles le sont
et les policiers pour moi on les met
dans une situation compliquée parce que
depuis le début de cette crise ils sont
derrière les français pour plein de
choses et aujourd'hui on demande à des
restaurateurs on demande à des
tenanciers de supérettes on demande à
des patrons de cinéma d'avoir un pouvoir
de police
alors moi moi je me pose juste la
question par rapport à ce passe
sanitaires comment l'encadrent pour moi
c'est une mesure qui n'a aucun
encadrement
enfin en tout cas aucun n'a pas vraiment
annoncé comment comment on délègue ses
pouvoirs de police un patron de
restaurant fossé mais qu'est ce que vous
attendez du conseil du conseil d'état
alors puisque le l'avant projet de loi
en tout cas ni d'impasses fréquences
pour moi le conseil d'état pour moi le
conseil d'état va censurer ce dispositif
emmanuel macron le sait très bien
emmanuel macron à des bénéficiaires en
faisant d'un effet d'annonce et ça a
très bien marché il ya je ne sais plus
il ya neuf cent mille personnes qui sont
connectés le soir même pour prendre des
rendez vous sur dr libre ça a marché et
je pense que il se laisse le temps que
ça marche avant la censure du conseil
d'état et il y aura une sans ce problème
problèmes techniques à victoria tedeschi
et je me retourne vers vous quand on
aura la liaision qui sera rétabli j'en
profite pour vous présenter ce qu'a dit
récemment que les mongols secrétaire
d'état chargée aux affaires européennes
j'ai entendu des gens expliqué qu'on
était en dictature les mots ont un sens
dans le débat public
la violence n'est pas justifiée
l'outrance et l'excès non plus
j'aimerais qu'il y ait beaucoup de
dictature comme la france dans le monde
bruno bartocetti même question emmanuel
macron fait-il de l'autoritarisme un
argument de campagne comme le dit le
spécialiste en communication arnaud
benedetti il était avec nous d'ailleurs
hier soir sur sur ce plateau
j'ai pas décrypter au boutte amour et je
ne suis pas capable ce qu'a voulu faire
passer comme message
emmanuel macron sks qu'il s'auto
proclamer indique nature dans ses propos
je ne le pense pas vous savez nous
travaillons dans une démocratie à nous
avons la séparation des pouvoirs je vous
l'apprends pas et nous continuons à
fonctionner ici donc on a pas on n'a pas
des directives aussi aux
ferme et aussi avec une ligne directrice
qui va du président la république
directement vers les policiers ce serait
grave nous sommes dans une séparation
des pouvoirs en france nous faisons
notre travail nous relevons des
infractions nous allons continuer à les
relever présenter ces effractions à la
justice et à le prendre des décisions
qui s'imposent et je crois pas que
l'adoption doit tomber dans ce piège là
alors après matière de communication on
est à une encablure des présidentielles
est ce que les mots ont un sens matière
de l'élection présidentielle c'est
probable pour un président sortant mais
en tout cas pas pour nous dans le cadre
du travail nous répondons à une
démocratie ça c'est sûr victoria
tedeschi a parlé d' effet d'annoncé inca
marché jusque y avait beaucoup de deux
personnes qui se sont inscrits sur les
plates formes pour prendre rendez vous
pour des premières injections antico
vide et aya olivier ferrand qui s'est
déplacé aujourd'hui dans un
vaccinodromes de chambéry en savoie
cette après midi il a annoncé que 96%
des personnes contaminées au kobe de la
semaine dernière n'étaient pas vaccinés
et que donc 3 millions de rendez vous
ont été pris depuis lundi christelle
pernette il ya eu un effet macro après
son allocution de lundi qui en est et
qui est en effet liée à la langue bien
évidemment c'est évidemment puisque
aujourd'hui on vous explique hier vous
avez le choix vous faire vacciner ou pas
excusez moi mais un choix entre être
vaccinés et avaloirs travail est ce que
c'est un choix
comment un choix c'est de choisir tel ou
tel vaccin éventuellement un mais c'est
pas de dire vous vous faites vacciner
et sinon vous perdez votre travail vous
faites vacciner sinon vous pouvez pu
aller en grande surface pour aller
acheter les produits les moins chers qui
existe c'est
ce que les classes populaires utilise
dont je fais partie un souci d'y accéder
on a le choix entre être vaccinés et
aller en cours pour nos enfants
je vous rappelle quand même que on est
toujours dans une phase de test que
c'est reconnu un que le test pour le
modern assez même pas moi qui le dit
c'est le consentement éclairé pour
loxane de conduite qui est fait en
suisse parce que je vous rappelle quand
même si on est toujours en phase test et
que en lien avec le code de nuremberg
puis le lait la déclaration d'helsinki
en 64 ans 66 le pacte international des
droits civils et politiques de l'onu en
88 c'est la loi en france sur le
consentement éclairé pour la permission
décès médicaux sur les services internet
qu'il ne faut pas agir parce que quand
on reprend les propos de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé qui date de cet
après midi je cite forte probabilité de
deux variantes possiblement plus
dangereuses au corps donc qu'est ce
qu'on fait on informe on a formé on fait
en sorte que les gens qui se font
vacciner puisse avoir un vrai choix
et puis savoir le consentement éclairé
c'est une obligation en consommant
éclairé qui a été redonné encore le en
gros mois de janvier 2021 par l'europe
et le 15 le 15 le 14 juin 2021 par
l'europe aussi avec la non
discrimination et l'angle est en train
de rentrer dans un système de
discrimination qui forcément créé la
défiance mais comment se fait-il
aujourd'hui qu'on ne soit pas notamment
comme en suisse à faire un consentement
éclairé un recto verso qui expliquent où
on en est pourquoi on vaccine qu'est ce
que ça apporte qu'est ce qu'on risque et
de signer cette déclaration pour se
faire vacciner
victoria tedeschi on a retrouvé la
liaison avec avec caumartin
propose de reprendre peut-être là où
vous en étiez ou si vous voulez réagir
aux propos de bruno bartocetti ou de
christelle pernette on a retrouvé
dimanche je me pose juste une question
le son a le son pourquoi les résidents
des pâtes par exemple n'ont pas une
obligation de se faire vacciner parce
que pour moi je pense qu'effectivement
sur les personnels soignants il ya une
obligation de protéger les personnes de
desquels ils s'occupent et il faut pas
que le coc ville devienne une maladie
nosocomiale aujourd'hui vous rentrez à
l'hôpital pour vous faire opérer vous
avez le coc vite vous n'êtes pas opérer
même pour une opération bénigne mais
pourquoi en ehpad ces gens qu'on a voulu
protéger depuis le début de la crise
n'ont ils pas une obligation de se faire
vacciner et ça c'est une vraie question
pour moi la cacophonie qu on a
aujourd'hui entre nous il faudrait pas
confondre la question des antilles
d'accéder antipas sanitaires moi je suis
content le passé ni terme et pour une
raison très simple c'est que je pense
que c'est une
c'est une comme l'a écrit françois b
vous avez des amis dans une très bonne
tribune du figaro ce matin
sacré sacré où je devais la maison
détruite et séries tv et surtout c'est
pas tout à fait qui s'inscrit dans une
ligne très différente de celle de damien
abad et je ne vais rien vous cacher en
me disant que je suis plus sur la ligne
de françois-xavier de leilani parce que
pour moi c'est pas la société dont j'ai
envie c'est pas j'ai pas envie de
montrer ma carte d'identité on allait
prendre maintenant prendre un café j'ai
pas envie de montrer ma carte d'identité
en allant au restaurant et je pense que
le patron de restaurant que le policier
non plus n'a pas envie de contrôler
patron restaurant et qui a une
obligation mais faria une sanction
pénale mais tellement forte et je pense
que les français ne comprennent pas
parce que les français ont l'impression
mes fonctions que c'est pas dissuasif
toujours les mêmes bien sûr c'est bien
sûr que c'est pour être dissuasif mais
si on n'a pas le même effet dissuasif
sur d'autres options d'autres questions
qui sont tout aussi importantes dans le
quotidien des français
et madame disait quelque chose de très
intéressant moi je travaille en zones
industrielles en zone industrielle en
france il a pas de petites surfaces de
commerces ya que des super u il ya que
des lidl et la vérité c'est que les
classes les plus populaires elles vont
faire
cours dans ce type de magasins et
aujourd'hui voleurs annoncé que le 1er
août ils pourront plus s'y rendent s'ils
sont pas vaccinés personne ne sera
vacciné le 1er août et pour moi il ya
tête une forme de mépris de la part du
président de la république d'avoir fait
cette annonce avec un temps aussi court
pour être vacciné et c'est ça que les
gens ne comprennent pas et c'est là vous
à mon avis emmanuel macron avait une
carte à double facette bien sûr il ya eu
l'effet d'annoncé mais il ya aussi un
effet de révolte qui peut s'y peut
s'emparer de des français et des mêmes
français que ceux qui ont été dans la
rue en novembre 2018 on rappelle alors
appel à la mobilisation samedi après
plusieurs manifestations donc donc qui
hier je me tourne vers vous à nouveau
bruno bartocetti les sanctions on venait
d'en parler
peut-être ce côté dissuasif a également
pour pour que tout le monde
au final
qu'on prenne cette idée de l'extension
du pasteur qui veut insuffler emmanuel
macron et que tout le monde se fassent
vacciner mais quand même les sanctions
sont lourdes 45000 euros d'amendé
un an de prison bruno berteau de
chéticamp vous interviendrez chez un
restaurateur fautif dans quel état
d'esprit est ce que vous serez alors
vous avez bien compris que c'étaient des
sanctions plateforme bien sûr vous dit
l'état d'esprit c'est certainement pas
de prendre du plaisir à ses actionnaires
un restaurateur en savez si vous
traversez la chaussée en dehors des
passages cloutés vous ne l'était aussi
une amende
je crois pas que beaucoup de citoyens se
font verbaliser
il passe en dehors des passages qui paie
est ce qu'on m'a demandé ma demande et
sur trois aux restaurateurs de faire
preuve de bon sens ils font preuve de
bon sens et on leur dit je prends les
restaurateurs ou d'autres professions je
vous ai oublié personne mais oh bien sûr
qu'ils vont faire preuve de bon sens
bien sûr qu'ils vont il y aura des excès
il y aura des débordements
c'est à cet endroit là qu'on devra être
ferme
d'après ai dit et ne va pas vous dire à
des débordements à quel type de
débordements à ce que vous vous attendez
en on sait quand il est là je vais du
couvre-feu il y avait beaucoup de
personnes qui étaient dehors à paris
beaucoup de jeunes qui faisaient la fête
et après c'était difficile de faire la
dispersion pour tout le monde rentre
chez soi et c'est là où on a vu des
échauffourées est-ce que là ça va être
la même chose peut-être que les gens ne
vont pas vouloir montrer leur pass
sanitaire et que derrière et bien
les tensions vont arriver est ce que
c'est ça que vous redoutez bruno berteau
sié lambert taccetti oui bien sûr qu'il
y aura des situations très tendues très
difficile et on va pas prendre en otage
jécistes des établissements qui
ressemblerait qui reçoivent du public
parce que là ce sera plus facile on va
dire à contrôler lorsque l'établissement
sera sera on va dire fermez poids zone
et j'insiste bien sur le fait qu' on
devrait être au bras de fer preuves
comme on l'a fait depuis le début j'ai
insisté là dessus
preuve de discernement fonctionner
situation imaginons je sais pas moi un
établissement de public recevoir 300
personnes alors que la capacité de 200
aulas as ici aussi on récidive à nouveau
sur ce genre de deux schémas on risque
sont montrés très sévère on a fait
preuve de beaucoup de tolérance de
pédagogie prenons pas des cas isolés
encore une fois il peut y avoir des
policiers extrêmement sévère on ne peut
pas leur reprocher non plus de lettres
et on est là pour être vrai on est en
contact avec la avec la population au
quotidien ainsi la population en rade
majorité nous soutient c'est parce
qu'elle le sait qu'on les comprend et
qu'on comprend aussi qui sait profession
difficile aujourd'hui des professions
tout le monde a souffert d'un autre dans
notre pays nous aussi nous sommes voilà
nous sommes confrontés dans notre vie au
quotidien à ces difficultés que nous
rencontrons et nous aurions quand même
des séries de raids pas faire preuve de
tolérance à l'endroit des citoyens qui
travaillent tout simplement je
préfèrerais qu'on donne les moyens la
justice se sanctionner plus sévèrement
les dealers voyez où les guetteurs bon
ben voilà on donne des peines forcément
planchers et plafonds
voilà même un juge fera preuve de
discernement en fonction des situations
si ce qui est important de retenir
creissels pernette de clés l'allocution
d'emmanuel macro lundi soir certains le
14 juillet mais je pense que vous avez
quand même exercer votre métier
d'ergothérapeutes
est-ce que vous avez discuté tous avec
votre avec vos patients qu'en pense la
patientèle de tout cela alors je dirais
que je suis détaché à temps plein donc
je suis plus en contact avec les parents
j'étais avec des enfants et je suis en
contact avec les parents d'enfants dont
je m'occupais pas ce que je voudrais
dire par contre c'est que le débat il
est toujours en train d'être tourné sur
les vaccins ou des anti vaccins je crois
qu'on est au-delà de ça on est en train
de passer dans un basculement me sens
utile sur la manière de gérer de gérer
les choses quand je parle de du fait
qu'on ne respecte pas des choses mais
primordial on est toujours en train de
se rapprocher de l'europe quand ça
arrange
là il ya quand même directive claire de
non discrimination de non discrimination
qui qui sont dans l'article 36 l'a22 du
document qui est sorti le 14 juin 2021
par rapport à la vaccination et qu'est
ce qu'on fait en france on applique un
applique la discrimination
on n'applique pas le consentement être
carrément chez qui comme victoria
tedeschi vous pensez que le conseil
d'état va retoqué cet avant projet et
j'espère j'espère parce que de toute
façon si en dehors des clous y compris
des coûts de la loi française là dessus
donc la langue française et européenne
et la loi internationale donc toujours
espérer que ça va être que ça va être
effectivement retoqué on est dans une
discrimination totale
les soignants qui vont être obligés
d'être d'être vaccinés comme je vous ai
dit dans les soignants sont considérés
aussi les aides les aides
à la vie les aides à domicile qui je
vous le rappelle n'ont pas touché le
ségur parce que quand il est question
s'occuper de personnes fragiles qui
rendent qui vont aller à l'hôpital ou
qui en sortent de l'hôpital ce qu'elles
font elles touchent pas les 180 3 euros
du ségur par contre quand il
al'obligation de quantième obligation
vaccinale pour les personnes fragiles
dans la santé elles en font partie donc
il ya des choses c'est pas identique
pour tout le monde
non seulement ça mais je le dis et je le
redis il ya quand même le problème du
consentement éclairé comment se fait-il
que nous n'ayons pas quand on va se
faire vacciner
un document qui nous rappelle le
consentement éclairé pour un pro des
vaccins qui sont toujours en phase de
test victoria tedeschi et vous êtes de
retour parmi nous on l'a dit il ya un
appel à la mobilisation
samedi il des manifestations également
hier antipas sanitaire anti-vaccins
difficile de le savoir qu'ils étaient
toutes ces personnes
au final on a senti qu'il y avait un un
début de fronde en tous les cas dans la
rue à quoi est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre
selon vous ces prochains jours ces
prochaines semaines
je voudrais juste revenir sur ce qu'a
dit ce qu'a dit madame
pour moi il n'y a pas de discrimination
parce qu'il ya pas de rupture d'égalité
hostens juridique du terme la rupture
d'égalité c'est des personnes qui sont
dans des situations similaires et qui
subissent des conséquences différentes
là c'est pas le cas en fait parce que
tout le monde a le choix de se faire
vacciner de faire un pcr ou pas donc en
fait juridiquement il n'y a pas de
rupture d'égalité
en revanche là où le conseil d'état peut
venir sanctionner le dispositif c est ce
que l'atteinte à la liberté individuelle
et proportionnée par rapport au but
recherché
et c'est là dessus qu'il faut à mon avis
réfléchir parce que c'est pas le
dispositif qui est qui et censurable
c'est le périmètre de ce dispositif
c'est les actes de la vie courante parce
que le conseil d'état avait déterminé
que les actes de la vie courante de m
être mis en dehors du pass sanitaire et
là il ya eu des extensions qui vont
justement empiéter sur ses actes de la
vie courante et c'est là-dessus pour moi
qu'il faut qu'il faut réfléchir quant à
une censure pour moi les mobilisations
qui peut y avoir elles peuvent être
multiples et je pense que le mot le mot
qui a carré
et sur toute cette crise c'est
cacophonie en fait on peut pas demander
aux français d'avoir confiance dans un
vaccin d'avoir confiance dans des
mesures à partir du moment où dès le
début on a eu quand même des paroles qui
étaient divergentes au sein même de
l'exécutif
des paroles qui ont et qui ont changé
emmanuel macron il ya encore deux
semaines ils disent écoeurés pas de
passionner terre pour les actes de la
vie courante
aujourd'hui on voit bien que c'est le
cas moi je pense toujours que c'est un
effet d'annoncé mais voilà il ya des
gens qui vont pas avoir ce recul là en
disant que c'est un effet d'annoncé des
gens qui vont se dire dès le premier
round je pourrai plus aller au super
heureux de ma zone de ma zone
commerciale à côté de chez moi et c'est
des gens qui vont mal le vivre c'est des
gens qui vont se dire bah moi on va me
sanctionner je suis un petit
restaurateur
on va me sanctionner alors que le type
qui fait des rodéos en bas de chez moi
tous les soirs on ne sanctionne pas et
c'est ça que les gens supportent plus ce
n'est pas tant la question du pass
sanitaire en tant que telle ou du vaccin
en tant que tel c'est un ras-le-bol qu'à
la société et qu'on les français sur les
sujets qui sont très multiples et
diverses et qui va s'exprimer avec cette
opportunité du pack sanitaire et des
réformes sociales qui vont arriver en
septembre
mais pour moi c'est vraiment avoir joué
avec le feu que d'avoir mis ça en place
avant avant la rentrée politique parce
que la présidentielle arrive et je pense
qu emmanuel macron voulait une certaine
manière préserver la campagne
présidentielle et donc c'est pour ça
qu'il veut pas de quatrième vague et qui
voulait une vaccination massive
mais pour moi il y aura une révolte
sociale à la rentrée et et on le voit
moi je travaille dans une usine donc je
sais j'entends les gens autour de moi et
les gens c'est pas du vaccin ou dupas
sanitaire c'est c'est dont ils ont donc
ça c'est vraiment on a le compris le
message
victoria tedeschi on approche de la fin
de cette demi-heure d'infos merci à tous
les trois en tous les cas d'avoir réagi
d'avoir des battues et et apporter
vos analyses bruno bartocetti je
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire au
home sud sgp police fo merci à vous
merci également à vous christelle
pernette ergothérapeute et militant
syndical à la cgt puis donc victoria
tedeschi et l'équipe nationale associés
jeunes républicains